do you know a word with 28 letters
technology impact assessment
will increase by the way at 38 that
's the technology
impact assessment committee there is also
in almost every federal state so I do
n't want to make fun of it but
and especially in connection with AI
we are in a phase of regulation
certainly makes sense must be a
little careful that the child is not
thrown out with the bathwater
on the podcast and in the video, whatever
that is soon to follow is a lot
different a lot especially first of all,
Ludwig von Reiche is probably in the
top 3 top 4 of the oldest  Podcast guests
who have been guests here in the last almost 600 episodes
then he represents a
company that you actually don't know at all,
namely Nvidia, which places
software chips very semiconductors if you
also say or GPS, but this company is
also the sixth most valuable company in the
world  So right behind Apple Saudi
Aramco Amazon Microsoft Google comes
Nvidia and how can it be what
they do what makes them so different. My
colleague Ludwig has been
on board for almost 20 years and must
have been very, very wealthy by the way
If you have a good golf
handicap and a lot to tell
about how you have been building
one of the most valuable
companies in the world here from Germany for 20 years, let's go a
warm welcome Ludwig from rich
hello good day I'm glad to be here
so Nvidia many don't know that we  Let's
start right at the beginning is
currently the sixth most valuable company in the
world, so we're talking about Amazon, I
think Saudi Aramco, the oil company Google,
Microsoft
Apple, and then here, so
to speak, that's the ranking, what are you doing, well,
we're actually not that
dissatisfied with the last ones  30 years that
we were not so well known, we are
the core manufacturer of graphics processors,
but sometimes graphics cards, which
have now found a much more possible application
and which, above all,
can drive high-performance computers and now also AI systems, but
these are not just chips  but above
all a whole world of
software platforms and technologies
around it,
which we don't sell directly to end users,
so in contrast
to the others you mentioned,
we don't take such a budget but
we sell them to other companies who
then sell them  into computer systems and
then they don't buy them from you now either,
but a normal
order from you is not just 100,000
chips or or or a million or
how much so you can go to Media Markt
and ask for an Nvidia card
for your PC and  then you get it, it says
Nvidia on it, but it's
not made by us, it
's a partner of ours, eh,
households can do that with the HP Lenovo model and others,
but also many, many others who
integrate this technology, which
thousands of us order, that's it
sure yes but also let's say
now a
meter for all metavers
efforts I think ordered from you
so there's always been a there are
really big customers with
you who are also very very
big software yes of course you can also do
more than  only 1000, so
to speak, and above all,
many of the hyper scalers of the large
cloud providers are of course with
our largest partners and customers because more and
more applications for which
our technology is optimized
can be used and you do
n’t necessarily have to look into your own
data center but let's
talk very briefly about the product itself what do these chips or
these graphics cards do exactly so what what
do the well good as the name says
graphics or GPU graphics processing
United 30 years ago the idea was to
display the
pixels graphics faster  Bringing it to the screen as quickly as possible
requires
a highly parallel execution of
transactions from computer
computing power and that was the basis
for the company, which has been continuously
developed and wherever
you have applications that
can be parallelized to a high degree,
these GPUs are optimal  can
therefore be used in many
computers and also from relatively many
suppliers what exactly is in there so what
does a graphics card consist of well
so basically it is a chip
that has been developed by us and
manufactured by a so-called contract manufacturer  we don't have our
own tipping factory we are a
so-called fables computer manufacturer
and that is built into a card that
you can then plug into a PC or
the entire processor is built
into the laptop directly by the laptop manufacturer, which
then also belongs on such a
card  Memory chips and others
that are added to the controller controller
that are obtained from others and then
assembled by a
manufacturer of such cards, but what
can you say, especially because you
would think at first okay, they make
hardware components or chips, that
means you have big factories  where they are
somehow spat out but that
you just fabulous you don't have what is
because your asset is our specialty is
the knowledge of the design and
optimization of computing power on the
smallest possible and most
energy-saving processor area
and we have thousands of
developers working on it more and more
because the transaction requirements, the
computing requirements are increasing enormously, especially with
today's AI solutions, so you have
contract manufacturers for you, so to speak, who
then build these chips according to your specifications
For example, the company Tier
SMC in Taiwan or Samsung in Korea are the ones
who then
take over the production, so animals
are still asked about it is one of the companies
because of which Taiwan may even
get particularly virulent right now
or there's no war
so far but  this whole tension
is at least that's why it's so
great, at least you can read it that way,
because this company is so important for the
world economy and the time interval
and the Chinese would like to have this company,
but how about this company is
what you've encountered before
Theory,
na theories, there are many drums
and I think
China will think very carefully about
what they are doing
in their
Taiwan policy and whether the
takeover, as you say,
would be the smartest solution, I'm not so sure
about the rest of
the chips produced by TierMC  are also
delivered to China and some of them are
also fully assembled in China,
so there are
commercial relationships as a result, but
TSMC, like fewer others, has managed
to optimize its own production together with machines from Europe in such a way that the in
are able to produce the
most complex chips of today's technology
in the so-called
sub-five nanometer range
in such a way that there is as little
waste as possible in this production, i.e.
the most productive that
can be produced where is there more added value in the end,
i.e. in what you do
or in what is animal  in she does
that complements each other very well i would
say we are both
successful companies and that
only works if both of them are
also economically successful so
in that respect it can't really be
pinpointed but
performance is an obvious
one  you can't
replace it that easily, the Chinese would otherwise
like to have it themselves, but that's not possible
and your performance can
obviously also be replaced,
so it's not just a company,
it's a whole ecosystem around it,
as they like to say of
training institutions for  the
engineers for the specialists who
can control such processes
that has been the case in Taiwan has developed in Taiwan
over many decades, by
the way, TSMC now also has
a production facility in the USA and in Europe people
are thinking about how
investments could or should be made here  to be able to
play again in the field of highly integrated chips so
we have to talk about Nvidia again
the company was founded in the 90s so it was
n’t that
old at all, exactly in 1993
by four engineers
in San Jose south of San Francisco
we were founded in the middle of Silicon Valley
and have grown and grown the main
founder if you can put it that way
Jens and one is still our CEO
this continuity over such a long
time I think you
see it very rarely you always look like that with a
leather jacket and  he's a bit like that,
although the company wasn't as big as Siebel
in the last few decades, when you see him like that,
you think he's actually
quite an edgy guy,
so what is meant by an
edgy guy in Hamburg, we can
talk about it again,
but  is, of course, on the one hand a
visionary
in recognizing new
technological leaps or
fields of application, but at the same time
someone who
can further develop the corporate culture, I mean when I
came to Nvidia in 2007 there were
around 6000 employees today we have
26,000 that is almost an order of magnitude
because you have to do a lot  do to advance the structures
and the culture a bit
and that is
largely his personal achievement that it
works so well, yes, but you have to
say the turnover per head is
gigantic, so you are 26,000
people, that sounds a lot at first
it's not that much,
in relation to the current
yes, that's in the middle
double-digit billion range, no,
but
that's quite clear, that's more than
the vast majority of German companies and they
do that, and
often 100,000 of them employees, well, that
's fine too  another industry
okay okay but it's usual to
obviously have so much upside down
well I've also experienced times with
Nvidia where it wasn't as extreme as it
looks today and um we're of
course at a point at the moment where
our technology is completely  There
is a particular demand perhaps
because we
not only
had the foresight that
something could develop from machine learning,
but we were certainly also a bit
lucky I can still remember
when the word machine learning was used for the
first time in a management
conference at Nvidia  it came up in the first place that
's about 15 years ago and we've
been working on it since then and well,
you can then
open up new markets to what extent is machine
learning an important topic for you?
I always thought that you
grew up at the beginning, so to speak, of
course  the classic computers then
also with consoles for Playstations and
similar made this whole wave
taken then now there is the topic of
self-driving cars where you notice
that you play a role
metaverse plays a role graphics card
you can quickly imagine that
that’s the right role then  but even
with the first mining, that is, crypto, also
a thing that is supported by a number of you
and creates a need and and
then of course finally somehow the
cloud solution I had already
talked about where you are still that is such
a thing that you make the big leaps that you
certainly there have been leaps, but of
course it has also become a bit of a continuous development and by the way, one thing comes to mind right now,
you are talking about
graphics cards, I also used the word
nowadays one
almost only speaks of GPU is that
former abbreviation of graphics cards
a bit similar to OMR
maybe because you also take care of
other topics than online-mark
so that was a technology
that, as I said, was agreed for which
was suitable for the processing of
parallel transactions to be
processed in parallel data streams  That
differs from traditional
CPUs, the
central processors of PCs up until today,
where relatively few transactions
can be parallelized and
then there were applications and
techniques to
make better use of this parallelization, which we of course also
promoted, and
we also have more software
engineers  as a hardware developer in the
company because we make software libraries available to our customers and
partners
that allow you to use this
technology really effectively and
quickly, you are
not an engineer or a developer yourself,
but I think you even
studied economics in Hamburg in a classic way  a
few years ago or a
few years ago and until then actually
via various stations I think I
ended up at Nvidia quite a while ago so it's um yeah that's the
short version of it I was
managing director of a startup that wasn't very young at the time
in 2007  Berlin
that we sold a video and
since then I’ve been managing director that I’ve
stayed there and meanwhile I’m
in the role for the whole German area
yes how big is Germany a good
600 employees,
more than a third of whom are engineers
the customers in the implementation of their
Project support,
of course we also have a
sales team here, we do a
bit of research here, we also work together
with German research institutions
there and
then quite a few other
computer scientists and engineers who
work on projects that are distributed around the world in
organizations so
knows a pure sales market where they
Technology is simply
created in some valley, so to speak, and then it
is then sold here, so to speak,
but here it is created itself, which is
absolutely not, absolutely, yes,
the acquisition in 2007 was a
company in Berlin that had about 50
patents for 3D visualization at the time, whatever
no, but I am  In 2002 I
then took part in two rounds of financing
with the founder and
then as I said we had exit
but we are talking about 100 million exit
or should be in the order of magnitude the
numbers but already relevant
millions with us well it was a
bit more and a video  was
interested in it because
research was also being done there because so-called
rendering technology was being developed there,
which was already being used in many other software products
and which Nvidia
could and then took to bring it into
other products and how
big was a video then, well, what
for a market cap that was
taken over at the time, oh my, I have to
pass, but we're talking about it now, I
've just said how
valuable the six is, currently in
German numbers I think it's almost
a trillion, in US numbers a
trillion  market cap we're
a trillion you have to
imagine that's a
really
monstrous amount of money that SAP is, I think, will
somehow be a little over 100 billion
and then that'll be a thousand
billion,
that has
accelerated a lot in the last year or
yes, that  It's like that, but
in the years that I've
been there I've also experienced that it
can go down again and we're on
a trend right now, so we're of course happy
about it and proud of it, but
the evaluation comes from
participants in the market who
have great expectations of it  we are working on
never fulfilling it but
so it happened again i just
looked it up here of course he's been talking since somehow you
can see this here for 10 years in
my in my share app about
or here all the time so it's happened
somehow more than
twentyfold in the last few years
since you've been there but you can also down
a very flat curve for the first 15 years
but I just wanted to
ask you or hope for you that
shares also flowed during the takeover
nvidia has had it since the beginning and still does
a program that opens up a stock participation program for all
employees who have been there for at least half a
year
gigantic for you what a
good time
it was in the last two that was a good time but I'm
not just saying that because what I
still enjoy about Nvidia is that
it is possible to
work on exciting topics, above
all to get into new topics
and
working together in this now
global context is sometimes
challenging if you have to
go into video conferences at weird times,
but
points of view quickly come together that
make the work fun for us  are your
biggest customers in Germany, so when
we sell you end up selling
here from the German
side, so we sell
almost nothing directly in Germany and of course we know
where our technology is used,
but they are our partners, they are the
big
manufacturers of  from Peter systems
that integrate nvidia processors and
then they are taken over by big customers
in the automotive field is a
bit different and our world's
biggest automotive customer is Mercedes-Benz
there we have quite a large team working
together with the Mercedes
engineers to integrate
our technology  for autonomous driving
in the
vehicle generations that
will be on the road from the end of next year
and in this respect this is a very important
customer for us,
with whom we also work very directly.
We also work
directly with BMW, for example you
mentioned mattervers earlier, we
have a technology  called omnivers,
which allows data streams from a
wide variety of sources, especially
three-dimensional
visualizations, to be
brought together in order to then be able to
make decisions, for
example for the development of a
factory or for the
further development of a production line -
that's something that BMW does and where we
support you, i.e.
automotive  Well, there is a
Deutsche Bank in Frankfurt, which is a
big
user of our technology.
It's all about simulating large data models,
and
of course there are also such applications
in other areas of
insurance companies, for example
when it comes to
quickly analyzing market movements,
and those are issues  for which we also
offer software platforms that they can then use
to develop their own applications
on it, that means
special computer,
these are
actually standard systems, standard
NVIDIA GPUs, but which are used for special
applications and that is
supported by software that we
give to the developers and that  then
build the special application on top of it okay okay
that means in the end I
quietly imagine that I will now have a large
insurance company Allianz which we now
or Munich Re or something like that
doesn’t say we’ll somehow make
a couple of laptops out of the
first time it  Shopping around the corner
because they can't do it or they
're not made for that,
we were there for our own
product or our own
machine and then you come into play
and help to operate this machine in a
concentrated manner, so the
machine is designed, it exists  to
buy it, you can place it in a
computer room or you can use it for
minutes or by the hour with a
cloud provider,
and I also mention this because
it makes it possible for smaller companies in particular
to use this state-of-the-art technology without investing heavily in the
Investment
and I think that is
an important issue, especially in Germany, where the
industry is very strongly supported
by medium-sized companies that
are not able and may not be able
to make large capital investments very quickly in
applications that they might think are speculative and they can  then
at
Amazon and web services to
take advantage of it, but also use it with German
providers in the cloud area, okay,
but behind it is your
solution, so that means they go to
Amazon, but in order for Amazon to
be able to fulfill that, they use your
products, they are there
installed in the data center and
running a piece of software from us that
allows individual customers to
use our hardware effectively
okay okay assistants but they buy
your hardware they buy our
hardware yes okay even in Germany
medium-sized companies would then also
buy your hardware or if  there
are all kinds of models
and you can do that on site,
but you can also run it in the cloud,
but from which use case or
from what size does
the company ask beforehand, so I
can imagine  if you are
now dealing with with with er Mercedes or
BMW that they are
building things in the cars, so to speak, where I
can imagine that your products
could play a role, but when I
am now because of
Zalando or I'll be a
dealer or maybe I'm now
a medium-sized
machine builder or somehow
produce if I
make agricultural vehicles then
my colleagues touch
some screws because recently I
could help when and where,
so in all cases I
would give an example  want to name where
the Nuremberg University of Applied Sciences has
built an application for a
medium-sized packaging manufacturer that
uses robots and thus optimally controls
the opening of the packaging
without opening and
closing it without
damaging the sensitive content of it
because data has to be processed
in the area of ​​the  Visualization are
so that you can see where a
packaging part is and really
that design of the packaging must
be known so that
the robot can start at the right place
to open it and that means this data
comes from different applications
sensors
design programs for packaging for
example and  they have to be integrated and
brought together in one application
and that happens on our
omnivers platform and that has
also been implemented there for a medium-sized company, for example  if
the
whole thing is to be scaled up and a whole
factory is to be operated above it,
then we are talking about a different
order of magnitude, but it works on all
levels
Germany is still the
home market of various other
chip manufacturers, so I'm the
only one who notices this
but I should have
looked at that but I
knew there is somehow a company for
the Aixtron, there is Infineon, of course,
there is somehow Siltronic, so
semiconductor film might have been
said earlier,
Germany has always been quite good, or
is it a  completely different segment than what
you do,
so I don't want to discuss them in
detail now, uh, they serve
some very special segments, we
also integrate
chips or processors from Infinion in
some solutions for vehicles, for example, because they
are simply excellently positioned there in the field
of sensors  for example
and in this respect we are also working very
intensively on the further development
of our presence here and for us
Germany is a very important
sales market but also a market where we
work together with universities and
research institutions that
are far ahead here in many areas
but understand it  that then there are
still competitors in parts of you
cooperation is the name of the game
so there are situations in which you
are in competition and in others
you work together so that is widespread in our
industry okay okay how
is it with this competition  In
relation to now let's say Apple or
Amazon themselves because you can read there too
that they want to produce more and more of their own
chips,
it's certainly always the
case that someone who starts working with our
technology then at some point
gets to the point they prefer  to
develop it yourself there are more examples,
but
ultimately it's a question of
consideration
when we can offer something that enables
someone to quickly state a
new solution, especially in the
automotive sector, we see that I
think it makes sense for others to go this route
decide that they
prefer to
first develop a hard or software themselves
and then it is
integrated, so there
is a lot in flux, but
we still talk to such providers
in the sense of a bit more sporty co-op
edition, even if they also see your
sales  yes also your market cap and
I mean if I now want
to satisfy Amazon's shareholders
and then you are probably also asking yourself
well where can I grow now and
where are there such big markets that
are relevant for me and then
you see if you see  also look,
if there's uh, nVidia makes
something there, maybe it would
n't be bad at all, of course,
I understand, but then you have to
assess whether what you're developing today
will start in two years' time when
it finds its way into a product
basically corresponds to what we will
then have in two years or
someone who leads today may
not
always be a leader in all aspects
of it, but
we are also developing further and
we will further develop our products
and then we will
hopefully be ahead of those who are
starting today  to develop new how do you
see Intel so because I
still have the advertising Intel inside that was
always the case in the chip manufacturer who
had built up the right brand, so to speak, very strongly back then today I assume
it wasn’t that much anymore
they are still in
almost  So in a high number of over 50%
of all laptops
in this respect I think
they are an absolute factor both in
competition for us but we
also work with Internet processors that
integrate the
latest generation of Intel processors into our
overall systems because the CPU from Intel
for our our largest systems  which are
required in the area of ​​high-performance computing, they are in there, so
it is still an important
provider of the technology that we
need,
I don't want to glorify it, we are
also in the competition clearly has intel,
like others,
again and again,
I don't want to say attempts now
undertaken but still trying to get into the
gpu market and that is
sometimes more successful and sometimes
not so good so we
basically see it as sporty if you like so
I'm trying
to develop a map like that in my head or
maybe in my head too  the hearing
listener meadow chip market looks so there
are German players we
talked about it there are, so to speak, those who are to
pull the manufacturers Taiwan there are
you then there are the classic
providers always quickly recognizes Intel there
is also a company from Holland
that has one  play a major role in the market
as ml yes and ASML in turn works with
technology from Zeiss from Germany
so the optics are always optimal exactly
yes SMS is the world market leader for
paprikation machines for chip
production that looks different
to do absolutely because you have MC
and others  as here in Taiwan,
the chips are manufactured on
machines from the Internet
and in this respect they are a very, very
important player in the
value chain for
chip manufacture is
also a European company that you
hear little about, but it is probably the most important in the concert
technology film in the world plays along
absolutely important but comes from Holland and
people always talk about Spotify in
Sweden or you look a
bit at SAP but in Germany
of course but what they do there
is also absolutely, so to speak, global state
of the game absolutely globally important  and
leading and yes they are still a
bit further away from the
end customer business of course and uh they
then deliver, so to speak,
so they understood the big
names that you hear again and again that is,
so to speak, a step earlier
then they come and then they come and then they
come  At some point in doubt in
Apple and Amazon or a BMW and then
a customer
comes along, and by the way, in addition to ASML, there are
also the manufacturers who
are the suppliers of the components for the semiconductors  do
n't even
mention them by name at the moment, but they supply the
intermediate products for this production and
distribute them halfway around the world, so I always read that there are
shortages, so it's kind of
this whole chip boom that I admit and
because now there are chips everywhere from
Cars to we somehow, uh, cloud
computing and all
future applications, so to speak, cell phones, of course, and
so that is always scarce, so
basically the supply of
quartz sand is not scarce, but of course there can
always be phases in
which certain productions or
certain components
are scarce  So at the beginning of the
corona epidemic, for example,
many manufacturers reduced their orders from chip suppliers because they were unsure
about the
further market development of their
end products,
then
the tip suppliers reduced their
orders from
component suppliers,
but these are not things you can do
can also start up again from one day to the next these
are not only very well-established
process chains, but also the individual
production steps
are very
finely and long-term controlled  to
the
contract manufacturers so that they can then
serve the market and
then they plan their production again
recently you presented your quarterly figures at the
end of May and gave out an
amazing forecast
and that’s why the axial
from one day is at the incredibly high
level by another 30%  risen
what's going on
the
markets say that the colleague
picked that out 217 billion a day a
value that is or more than
any German company is worth he
just increased it
yes it doesn't come before
most people but
oh well I mean we  are observed by over 50
analysts and they make their
own forecasts and when you
submit quarterly reports and then their
forecasts
significantly exceed
what I'm still forecasts but
say that you see
significantly more sales being
generated in the next quarter and beyond  than the analysts
predicted, then
of course there will be a bit of movement
speculation if you will,
because one expects that this will
develop into a different magnitude
carried out of the
business which already delivered in the last quarter
and we see that the
investments in ki solutions will
increase dramatically and underneath there are
essentially GPUs
and a lot of them of us
so
in which now more and more industries are seeing
like they are in ki-  solutions how to
get to ki-solutions too quickly
you need these resources that we
can supply so with every query on chat
gpty
also on the tool but there is
a transaction running on an Nvidia chip at the back
yes so open aires but also
partners of yours yes
okay um
the cheapest you on the
German market, so I mean
you are somehow in the company and you have a
relatively good overview, so one of the
largest companies in the world in what is
probably one of the most relevant
areas of technology in this scene gives
what role Germany is
Germany is  incredibly important
for us and for many fields of application
I mentioned Deutsche Bank, I
spoke earlier about Mercedes, which
invests heavily in AI-based
solutions,
so for us in Europe it is
an absolutely central market, on the
other hand it is also important that
we in Germany are more concerned with this
technology and
are always proactive
there are many
professorships for artificial intelligence
there has been a German center for
artificial intelligence for a long time
where
we in Germany are a bit later
than elsewhere is ultimately the
commercial implementation
if you look at it  how many
companies are on the market today with solutions
then there are
a few unicorns in Germany there is deep l there is
all alpha after that it will be a
bit thinner and the companies are just
a bit smaller
I think it is very important here
to do even more  investing in
the development of competency structures
for
training courses, to put it bluntly,
at
universities at technical colleges in order to be able to
leverage this potential,
so jonas is the founder
of everything, you
probably don’t know him personally,
okay, so he  was here in the podcast a few weeks ago
and he said
he's actually quite optimistic because
many of the AI ​​um researchers or or or
developers who are leading come from
Germany and produce really top
people from Germany, I was quite
surprised that he was like that
desk hypnosis has many go
to the USA or something afterwards, but you have to be careful,
but they come here first, yes, that is
correct, yes, and there are many
institutions that are already
working in the field of research,
the next step is the implementation of
research  and making it attractive
is sometimes a bit of
a mental problem if you've been in research for a long time,
there are many for whom the step into
commercial application is somehow not
as natural as perhaps
culturally in the USA, where uh the
cooperation between companies
and
universities has a longer tradition
no, but we see good steps there, but
I think it is important that there is
a little
more open discussion in the public sector than in many
new fields of technology in the
past, so in general  a
digitization in Germany well that
's a case that has been discussed for a long time
no and do
you know a word with 28 letters
technology impact assessment
can be increased by the way at 38
that's the technology
impact assessment committee there is also
in almost every federal state i.e. me  I do
n't want to make fun of it, but
and especially in connection with AI,
we are in a phase where regulation
certainly makes sense. You still have to be
a little careful that the child is
n't taken out with the bathwater
when we're talking about the AI ​​Act
and its implementation  on a
national level, it is
certainly important to gain trust in
the wider population so
that
AI is not associated with a fear factor
and I think German providers in particular
all show Alpha, for example,
how they approach it very
responsibly
on the other hand, we should see
that  we also enable experimental spaces
and also create some
legal
safeguards for this, which make it
possible, for example, to be able to conduct research with large
data models in the medical environment,
the last of the
statements made by leading AI people from the USA
who say must be careful that
the economy is taking away from us
and that  so to speak, the end of the world is
now where can I have matured
so that sounds pretty
threatening it's great to say the discussion let's
say it like that but I think if I dealt with it
responsibly
I wouldn't make this extra, this
extreme scenario my own
[music  ]
However,
we have to see that we are
dealing with a technology here, the consequences of which
cannot be assessed as concretely
as one might
know in other fields of technology,
and therefore if one
tackles the regulation now, one should
manage to design it so flexibly
that  you can continue experimenting and
that you may adjust the regulation
later, and that quickly and
not again through years of
discussions and that is a
challenge, but I think we are
on the right track with the AI ​​Act,
which has not yet been fully discussed but
will come  it is now important to
move forward in this sense, why have
you actually had
such a consciously
reduced profile in the last few years, so we
had Nvidia, we were just
talking about where it says now and that's a
few years old yesterday, but still, um
Brand or there is no
special presence there is also
no
increased value to perceive but
the feeling
well, on the one hand we have
always been a b2b player in principle we are of course also visible towards end use in the
area of ​​products that go more into gaming
have
regularly performed at Gamescom
we traditionally have many in the gaming sector who
analyze our products which, if you like,
were and are natural influenza
before the word influenza
even appeared, no, and
in this respect we are not quite unknown, but we are
kicking it  At the moment, developments
in general awareness are much stronger
in the general public, behind
which our technology stands and
in this respect we are dealing with it
hope that we are in good spirits
that we can influence
this discussion a little
further in a positive sense  But once
again we are sticking to the
fact that our business model is essentially geared towards
making companies successful, giving companies
the opportunity
to develop this technology and especially
in Germany, so the nabling of
companies is a very important goal
for us, you are actually too  with the
new Apple Vision Pro glasses included
or is that also
was your technology, so to speak, that's
so new I do
n't want to comment on that just yet, but
we're not directly involved on
the other hand,
I could imagine that it's a
whole  Ecosystems of applications, in
turn, are created, both
behind them and in the application, i.e. in the
infrastructure where it is then used,
and I could
imagine that this will also affect our users
and customers and thus also us,
so do you believe in the product?
I believe in it
[Music]
augmented technologies
and that comes from a
different area of ​​application for us, where
product design is concerned. Being able to visualize a product design
early on in
an environment that is as natural as possible is
an enormous productivity factor
and such technology is excellently suited to this,
i.e. with every new
technological leap  with every new
invention at Apple
you will also be happy because somewhere in this
new ecosystem
your products will probably already
be relevant,
so we are happy about new
fields of technology in which we
can play a role and I could
imagine that happening here, yes
Did you suffer a bit
from the crypto downturn,
I mean, crypto does, but this
mining is no longer as attractive
as it was two years ago,
so the whole issue of crypto is not
something that we approached strategically from the start
we
came along a bit more by accident
I can honestly say that
we tried
to develop special products for this market
and I think that will continue to
play a role but it is not a
central topic for us, so what is the central topic
Probability is
a very central topic is AI and
solutions around AI and there is
a lot to do on all levels
from the
individual user to
the architect in his or her
workplace, who thus
gets support for the development of models
that can then be analyzed in real time
for example on their construction
[music]
since the day before yesterday 70 70
I'm old when OMR podcast
I never expected so that's
amazing that's already
actually over-retired entry
age, so to speak, a long time ago but it's
still fun wow awesome  this is crazy thank you thank you
but it's for you that you
're still the next 10 years old
or or what would I have what I would have there
so I'll do a bit more it's
just fun and my wife
still lets me
so it  would have been young yes I mean
you are constantly coming up with new topics
and that is what I just
find exciting and in this respect
in your company one of
the older ones or probably
logically there
is at least one older colleague in Germany
and it is easy  with you so much just
skin that the
person I need is there or is it
just I just feel like it and and
then the performance is
obviously good enough that he says yes of course
we are an American
company and there is one in Silicon Valley in
particular  there is a
pronounced concern about aging police,
that this obsession with youth
has sometimes been lived for a long time and
we consciously counter this by
allowing older colleagues to stay with us if it
makes sense from the company's point of view
and there is  then partly flexible
working time models for it and
in this respect it
is part of the
corporate culture for us on the other hand there are
colleagues who say that when they are in their mid-50s
or whenever you are looking for something
new you want to do something completely different I just sent
a
goodbye message yesterday
sent such a colleague in the USA who
no longer wants to deal with completely different topics in technology and there is
something like that so we are
flexible there but for you there is a
manageable amount of time, so to speak, four five
years you can imagine
maybe but maybe  but also
less I also have a few
other personal interests and, for
example, to think through what I am
opening up here in this regulatory environment
I also
studied political science I find it
very exciting
and I think there are exciting
things to do there  In Germany we
also have to think a little bit about two other things in order to
maintain innovative strength, i.e.
what is being discussed right now about the new
working time regulations I
hope this is not the last and
ultimate conclusion
I don’t know how it is at OMR we
made up our minds  our
thoughts too, that should be yes, so
I brought a few ideas into the
discussion, let's see if
he can get a little further with them,
not
exactly in innovative areas where we
people don't
pay our colleagues to be present  then
sharp clocks have to be introduced
linked so German politicians know
that I exist or are there
individual parties or individuals
with whom we understand that we will
activate that I will soon be back
in Brussels because many there he is
now being decided not on the subject of
working hours that is  at European
level but with all the framework
laws that are currently emanating from the EU, it
's our turn yes you
know your personal connection to
Jensen Wang so the founder of
Nvidia is that you have contact
you know each other or yes I mean he  bought us
because he did it personally or was
it somehow or do you have
permanent contact afterwards or something like that,
we have a very flat
company
hierarchy that basically consists of what
a colleague recently put it
consists of
Johnson and the rest of us
so between me and him there is a
single level of hierarchy and if I
need him then he gets a direct
email and I also usually get
an answer within a couple of
hours
as he is very busy
personally involved in what is happening in all areas of the company
and will soon be back in
Germany
we have locations in Berlin
near Aachen and in Munich our
largest location has become even larger in Munich
because we have moved a large part of
our Russian office there
then we have a smaller
ticket there in Stuttgart, so that's
spread out a bit over the
fourth and where are you mostly yes I
'm mainly in Berlin but also
a lot in Würselen and in Munich and
on the way Würselen is the place near
Aachen where we have ours
We have a branch there, we made the first
investment in Germany in 2003 and
took over a small tipping company, a
graphic tip company that
was spun off from the RWTH, that's how the history
of Nvidia began in Germany, in
Würselen
you're still in the USA, so tell me
now  many sometimes like that, up to
four five times a year,
then a couple of years not at all and now every now
and then because we notice that
personal contacts are
becoming important or are important again, both internally and when dealing with customers,
but internally we have
extremely much communication is virtualized
and we travel a lot less overall
we have also
had a customer event regularly since
2007/2008 brought together once a year in sanosé
there were then in 2018
I was the last time in 2019 I was
the last time there
were about 8000 registered
participants  who then also traveled
there, for the most part we
did very little virtually, maybe there were
limits to the cinema, but that was it. The
next year it was over and then
we had 80,000 registered
participants for the virtual version
and that still improved  further
increased by the years of the pandemic
and
now we keep thinking about how
best to bring virtual and presence
together,
yes, we might have to
talk,
all right, so let's start
this topic right here when
the podcast is over, um, I wanted to
Thank you of course for coming
so on various levels
madness story and
important update for us to understand how
is this landscape in the
background uhm thank you very much thank you
also everything is clear ciao ciao